名探偵コナンのテーマ(はじめん歌唱)
とぅるとぅとぅ～
こんちわ　あっ違った
あ
やあ　僕の名前は
名探偵コナン
僕はぁ
ある黒ずくめの組織によって
体が小さくされちゃって
あのー、うん、そうだよね
あのー
事件解決するよ！　えへ
こんにちは、名探偵コナンです
頭脳は子供
や、頭脳は大人でした。
見た目も大人
名探偵コナンです
あの、コナン君のアニメによく出てくる
犯人っているじゃないですか、あの黒いあの人
戦慄（せんりつ）が家に来るんですけども
もしこの僕、コナン君の家に犯人が居たら
戦慄はどういう反応をするのか
これをねちょっとね確かめてみたいと思います。
実際多分ですねあのコナン君に出てくる犯人が
家にいるとめちゃくちゃ怖いと思うんですよ。
真っ黒だし、顔が怖いし
まさきにばれないようにね、こっそりまさきに忍び寄って
最終的には・・・まさきを
行くぞ犯人
蘭姉ちゃん
まずは顔を切り取っていきます
これだけあればどこで居ても、ほらだって
ほら・・・あ～
ほら、どこに居ても犯人じゃん
えっと、これを今から後輩に付けていきます
ここ？・・・大丈夫です・・ふっ・・
あははははははは!!（爆笑）
ぱちぱちぱち
いいよ、いいよいいよ
多分ぱっと見わかんないでしょ
ちょっとかなり変だけど
これでも結構犯人だよ
後輩）ぐふっくすくすくす
はじめん）くふふふ
とぅるとぅ～とぅ～
とぅるとぅ～とぅ～とぅとぅ～
とぅるとぅるとぅとぅ…
とぅとぅ
とぅとwww（笑）
わたくしコナンとこちらの犯人の二人で
まさきがこの犯人に殺人されるね
ちょっと、ドッキリをやっていきましょう
頼むよ
と、取れそう
うわぁ、怖！
これさー。マジで怖いよ。
俺、これ、多分。実際いたら、マジで逃げるもん。
うぁ。怖い怖い怖い
はい、は～い
がちゃちゃ　　うっし
じゃあ、待ってて
（ホラーな曲）
まさき）コナン君じゃない。（オネェ…？）
まさき）w
まさき）普通にどうしたんだろうと思って。
まさき）今日そういう動画なのかなって思っちゃった。
メインが。
まさき）普通に、あたりしか入ってないレベルの、
やばいやつだった
それをたぶん探るのは神宣とか賄賂とかしか
まさき）ないのか。　はじめん）うん。
いや、でも強いよ！　ペンデュラム…エクストラデッキ行っちゃうじゃんね
だから普通に強いと思うんだよね。
まさき）普通に、　あれ。
なんだっけ。
まさき）ふはは（www）え、まって?　（ピアノスタート）
え、なんでなんで
うっふふふふふふふふwwww
待ってwwww
wwwwwwwwwww
そんなのんびり話し聞くとこじゃなかったね。今多分
コナンくんこれで終わりじゃないよね？
なにもいなかったよ！
名探偵コナンのテーマ(ピアノ）
終わったくない？
まさき）全然全然
無理でしょこんなの！突破口できないよ
まさき）これだって普通じゃないとないと…動けない
はじめ）「セフィラの神託」発動　まさき）はい
えっと発動時に、えっと「セフィラ」モンスター一体を手札に加えます
はい
きついな
どれサーチしようかな
スキドレでしょう？
はじめ）「レッド・リゾネーター」通常召喚　まさき）はい
でっ
えーっと
はじめ）「ウェンディ」セット　まさき）はい
はじめ）「ピリカ」セット　まさき）はい
ここでペンデュラム召喚
いやっ
まさき）早いところじゃねえ、これ　はじめ）たしかに
バニキ落としｔ
まさき）うわはハァーー
（笑）
えっ、なになに？
まさき）うふ～は～ふ～
なになに？
まさき）www　　はじ）え？？
マサキくん大丈夫か？
(まさき) www
撃たれた！
名探偵コナンのテーマ(ピアノ)
僕、スーパーハッカーなんだ！
見てて、マサキくん。
まさき）犯罪者じゃねーか。（笑）
まさき）『君の名は』公開記念で、
まさき）秒速とかアベマでやってるんでしょ。
嘘！
君、アマゾンの使い方知ってる？
まさき）アマゾンの使い方…（笑）
～ばん！！
うわーーーーーー
名探偵コナンのテーマ(ピアノ＋はじめん替え歌)
エッグ矢沢～
ボンボ～ン～TV～
エッグ矢沢ボンボ～ン～TV～
エッグ矢沢
ボンボンTVセイキンさん～
とぅるとぅとぅるとぅ～とぅとぅ～
ボンボンTV～セイキンさんボンボンTV～
（フェードアウト）
2人（爆笑）
まさき）もう一回じゃねーよ